hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on 400 and today we have tons
of info to talk about today some patch
notes from 2.01 which is which what
released on marching fire just this
Tuesday and on top of that we have a new
event teaser that's coming next week and
lots of other stuff so let's get started
with today's video first up is patch
2.01 there's a lot in this patch and a
lot we already know like breach mode
Arcade Mode etc so I'm only gonna really
be talking about the new info so if you
do want to see all the other stuff that
it's old news or anything that I didn't
cover you can check the link in the
description for all the patch notes but
breaches at a 55% increase on the XP and
a 25% increase on the steal this isn't
new this was originally not in the open
test when we had it back in September
but now it is now in the full game so
that's why this isn't an increase on top
of what we already had this is just
stating why there's such a big amount of
XP gained in this mode I've managed to
gain about a rep every two hours in this
mode so it's crazy XP I definitely
recommend using this mode if you want to
gain trap fast for a new hero on top of
that advanced hero tactics is now in the
game we talked a lot about that last
week it's just a lot of more practice
stuff a lot more of the feat changes are
also being introduced as well one of
them being catapult is now 2,000
milliseconds which is a crazy huge nerf
if you guys have played for each
muttering the four of you four modes you
probably have noticed that catapult is
pretty darn slow and it's really not
that useful anymore there's a ton of
other patch notes as well wood sharpened
blade and stuff like that but you can
check that as well like I said in the
description on top of that are a Musha
got a nerf even though it does say it's
a buff he does have more damage on some
of his attacks but he struggles to land
the move so he has little bit options
with slightly higher damage I personally
thought this was a buffer or Musha but a
lot of the pro tournament players did
state that this was a nerf so I'm gonna
go based off of their opinion but it
does kind of make sense he's getting
slightly more damage but he still can't
land the move just as common so that's
gonna be a little bit of a nerf to him
sadly on top of that minions can also
interrupt executions and revise if
you've noticed in the four of you for
most of the past couple days so that is
a new thing and unlock rolling is not as
viable as it was before it really only
happens in a high-level play but it's
still a good change nonetheless for the
tournament players and there's also a
system to avoid the same players in
duels in Dominion like the find new
opponent except this time it actually
works if you leave a game or leave to
some type of match and then queue up
again within 5 minutes you will not be
put in with that person once the 5
minute mark goes away then you will
eventually be queued up with that
a chance to be cued up with that person
because I don't want you to be sitting
in a lobby for 10 to 20 minutes and
stuff like that just trying to find that
person when they could have matched you
up with that guy on top of that there is
team shuffling it's basically
rebalancing the team so that it's unfair
and it won't break up the teams of
people so don't worry if you're if
you're in a group your team will not be
split up but like I said it's supposed
to shuffle the team's a bit there is
team swapping before the game but then
there's also team shuffling which is
during the match or I believe it's in
the beginning of the game so it's not a
huge detriment they don't want you to be
at the very end of the match then they
swap you and then you could have won
then you end up losing so I believe team
shuffling so a team swapping is before
the game but team shuffling is right at
the beginning of the match there's also
some high res textures if you can turn
them on in the settings but it only
really works in the hero menu now I
believe this is only on console but if
you want to add it it's up to you I
personally have them on and they look
really nice the DLC heroes are also
discounted so Xiamen are a Musha
Highlander shinobi Centurion and
gladiator those characters are now
discounted they go for 10,000 still
instead of 15 steel if you haven't
bought them already so you can
definitely do that if you want and then
last bit of info is that if your
opponent quits in ranked mode you win
the match and you get the rank score for
it that used to be a huge problem in the
beginning of the season of season 7
where people just leave the game and
they wouldn't lose any score that is not
the case anymore they've officially
fixed that and then lastly we have to
talk about the biggest teaser or
whatever this is for next week's event
coming out on October 25th which is
exactly next week Thursday we have new
show shinobi warlord and PK with all
glowing yellow eyes and a giant cowboy
skeleton in the front I don't know what
all of it is but all I know is that it's
spooky season and shits about to get
crazy next week let me know your
thoughts about what you guys think about
what the skeleton is you know why does
the skeleton with a hat why there's a
skeleton in the first place is it going
to be like the endless March stuff from
last year is it gonna be some similar to
that or is this totally something new
I'd love to know all of your thoughts
just based off this photo like I said
next week you're gonna get all the info
cuz it does come out next Thursday so
stay tuned to the channel and I will
keep you guys all to date on what the
new event is and what it entails what
that guys like to be if they do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the
informational SATA fauna that we balance
changes hero updates to patch notes
leaks all that good stuff like that
teasers everything on the informational
side of fauna I like to cover on top of
that guys my two most recent videos
would be on screen if you guys do want
to check that out with that guys hope
ever history day
for watching the video and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]